good morning bachelor nation thank you
so much for joining me at roses and Rose
a live here on entertainments night i'm
lauren zima here with Anneliese Puccini
round of applause for Annalise she made
it through
she is not traumatized Paradise is fun
Annalise I have so many questions for
you I'm sure you guys do too so leave
your questions and comments on our
social media platforms I will get them
right here on the iPad but let's dive in
let's talk about Monday night's episode
we're looking ahead to tonight's episode
Paradise just gives us so many gifts are
you really glad that you went on
paradise because I'm so glad it is such
a different experience like The Bachelor
when people say how was it I'm like The
Bachelor nope not for me not fun but
paradise is like amazing it's just it's
fun it's yes there's obviously still
like the drama and the stress and
anxiety of am I gonna stay another week
am I gonna find love all those things
but it was just fun we are seeing such a
different side of you and the best way
possible the analyse that we knew from
RE season of The Bachelor was
traumatized by a lot of things how
realistic was that to who you are
I mean what you saw was all was all true
it all happened but from Bachelor to
Paradise I really took a lot of time to
focus on me and do a lot of work on me
so I actually went to therapy I started
working with a personal trainer I just I
think I took care of myself and so I was
in a much better headspace when I went
to Paradise really so did being on The
Bachelor make you realize there were
things you wanted to work on about
yourself I think I was just not aware of
how stressed out I was in my real life
and when I got to Bachelor I was just
like oh my gosh tailspin and I think I
sort of it was a it was a rude awakening
of like things that I needed to deal
with in my personal life and so I did
and I I just felt like when I went to
Paradise I was I just felt like an ELISA
Diaz like I was calm I felt like ready
for everything interesting because I
mean in bachelor and we were just
talking about this but of course you go
on the show and suddenly you don't have
a phone you don't have your family and
friends you don't
know what the news of the world is so is
what happened for you it sounds like
that all of that stuff taken away made
you kind of look at yourself a little
bit it did and I didn't even realize it
when I was there cuz I was just you're
in this bubble so you don't even really
realize that you're spiraling out of
control until you you remove yourself
from it and then you're like oh man
that was not a good look on me like what
what do I need to do differently in my
life so that I'm I'm a better healthier
human being so I think it was it was a
good opportunity for me to just grow as
a person and then like I said when I got
to paradise then I just felt like I was
I felt like I was the me that I wanted
to be so if you look back at those
scenes from Bachelor when you are you
know crying about the bumper cars or the
the I think the dogs what's your
reaction to watching that
it's hard watching it back you know
because the thing is is that those
things actually did happen and so when
people make fun of it or like say that
it wasn't genuine or true I'm like okay
well it actually did happen and it was
what you know yeah it was it was
something that unfortunately it came out
the way it did on the show in a in like
a humorous way so it made fun of it but
at the same time those are you know you
have things as a child that shaped who
you are as an adult so yeah I mean it
was yeah I was hard watching it back but
it's I mean it's in the past I'm fine
when I did wonder for you if the thing
is that was really kind of all that we
saw we didn't see and now in Paradise
we're seeing so much more of you so how
would you describe in a couple of words
the differences or the version of
analyse we're now getting in paradise
like what's different about you this
season I think this this time around I'm
just I'm like so much more ready I feel
like I had things in my life sort of
it's like one of those things that when
you have everything lined up and then
there's just that one missing piece I
just felt like everything was sort of
lined up right before I went to paradise
like things were actually I didn't have
my life wasn't in chaos so it was easier
for me to just enjoy myself and have fun
and actually me well we saw a lot of
enjoyment last night we have questions
and comments coming already Lane says
you seem like such a nice person you're
one of my favorites on paradise yes it's
been so fun to watch you Sophia with a
question that I intended to dive into
later but let's just do it
because the people want to know Sofia
says what do you think of this whole Tia
and coltan situation I TN coltan I just
feel like need to figure it out and and
I feel for them because they aren't
being they are giving themselves or
anyone else the opportunity to really
get to know them because they are just
in this weird little again bubble that
they are trying to figure out like are
we aren't we do you know but then they
don't want to date and other people so I
mean while I was there I kept just
saying P need to leave and figure this
out in the real world because right now
they're just kind of doing their own
thing and it's it's just not working so
yeah I feel like Colton has one foot in
one foot out yeah and it's like either
jump in or close the door exactly it's
that he I mean he said he wanted to
explore things with her but oh he also
wants to be open other people right I
also feel it's all based on what seems
like not a lot of time that they spent
with each other out in the real world
but then it all got magnified on
Bachelorette and now in Paradise
ultimately do you think that they're a
good fit I like them together they're
both just so sweet and I mean I think
that there could be a future for them so
do you think that Colton needs to step
it up like is it more the fact that
they're not able to figure it out more
on him than on Tia yeah I think it's
definitely a decision that Colton needs
to make right now
tea is all in obviously a woman watching
Tia I'm kind of like do you just walk
away it does like with Chris and with
Colton I loved her calling Chris out and
I felt like he was that I felt so bad
for her in that conversation last night
I felt like I was watching someone have
to talk to somebody who's just on a
different wavelength I mean she's
sitting there like but you said you were
into me and I knew kiss Krista like what
did you think of the Chris moments last
night I it was hard I was watching it
for my girlfriend and they were like ah
we hate Chris and I was like I actually
really loved him he and I became really
good friends and so it's hard for me to
watch it back cuz I'm like I have a soft
spot for Chris but then at the same time
I'm I'm like how that's well the reasons
referring to himself as the goose and
wearing a headband most of the time it's
overwhelming it's I mean the thing is I
felt so on his side after men tell all
I thought he really owned what he did
wrong on Bachelorette he apologized he
had that cute moment with the choir and
and paradise I'm like what are you doing
man and yeah yeah I don't know um I just
I feel like he didn't handle it well at
all and I think we're all there to fly
in love and so like it's understandable
that you're gonna explore other
relationships and kiss other people but
at the same time have conversations with
people and like let them know what's
going on
so last night I mean take yourself back
to when you were there at this time of
paradise
watching what Tia was dealing with with
Chris and with Colton were you wanting
to tell her pick Chris pick Colton or
and forget both of them I I felt like
she needed to leave I felt like she
wasn't in a headspace to actually find
love unless it was gonna be with Colton
and he wasn't all-in so I sort of felt
like both of them needed to leave and
figure it out but why do you think he
wasn't all-in honestly I don't know I
think probably it was he probably still
had a soft spot for Becca and it was
just all too soon I feel like TM may
have been a little bit at that point of
stove like the rebound of like wait
maybe I like you and maybe we should
pursue this but then also I still have
feelings for somebody else so I'm like I
don't know it was it was a there was a
weird energy I liked them together but
it was still kind of a weird energy I
thought I thought yeah isn't it well and
then we saw crystal very quickly have a
mourning meltdown after Chris said he
needed to go get a tequila I was like
what time of day is this Chris needs to
hit the bar Crystal's breaking down in
tears already how did you feel at that
time about Chris and crystal as a couple
I think it was probably the realization
for crystal that she was like wait
actually maybe I really do like this guy
cuz I do think I mean it's a weird
environment anyways but when you're
having a breakdown moment over a guy
that soon into it it is it is a kind of
a nice thing sometimes because you're
like okay wait maybe my emotions and my
heart are actually telling me something
that I'm not listening to so yeah she'd
been with Kenny Kenny really had dates
around in Paradise I saw last night
we'll get into that Mandy such a good
question she wants to know are you now
on good terms with Jordan and what did
you think of Jordan and Jenna together
Annelise I felt like you you snap back
pretty quick which I was going to be
about well the thing with Jordan is so I
went into paradise just thinking I'm
gonna be open like that was
my number one thing I'm like I've been
single for three years now and so I'm
doing something wrong let me explore
other types of people in relationships
and Jordan was so sweet and he was just
really pursuing me so hard the first
week that I I was like okay you know
what like I haven't had a guy ghost this
gung-ho for a while so let's see where
this goes um I have no hard feelings
towards Jordan at all I think he's a
great guy and I knew it the minute Jenna
walked in and I was like okay well that
just makes sense like this doesn't
really make sense would that make sense
so what made you think that made sense
everyone seemed to see their connection
so quickly I mean I I know genic from my
season but then also getting to know
Jordan over those couple days I was like
this just they're both so quirky I was
gonna so lot of them cute it working
they just they literally they just make
sense so like the same person in guy and
girl for I'm like it just made sense and
I knew I think that's why I was so
emotional about it because I kept
thinking well shoot this is sort of my
chance and now I might be going home and
I think that realization that early on
is like a hard thing to deal with
because you want to see other people
come in and but Jordan is I think he's a
great guy and I honestly the minute I
saw them together I was like this I'm
happy for them because we did see a
moment where and I don't know sometimes
editing makes things look like they
happen at different times but when
Jordan and Jenna were on the date it
looked like you were saying well I'm
expecting to leave with him putting a
ring on this finger so I was like that
jumping that far ahead
but I think I was I think that's the
thing I was open to the idea of that
happening with somebody and it and I
kept thinking back to like the Carly and
Evan sort of situation where like there
is somebody who you're like mm because
what I mean realistically Jordan Ike I
kept going mm I don't know if this is
ever gonna be a thing I don't know if
this could ever work in the real world
but you feared as we were trying to make
sure you close look I don't want to
close the door yet and so um so I
thought like I mean who knows why not
why not he's in a full floral vest pant
situation why not I felt bad for Jordan
about this David thing because it really
just seems and it was already happening
on Bachelorette but really impaired
it seems like David was just trying to
get under his skin which I'm not a fan
of because I'd like Jordan yeah okay I
mean they can they just go at it for for
a while I think they were to come I
think they have this like love-hate
relationship where they like like to
push each other's buttons well we got a
little tease that on tonight's episode
we might see Jenna making out with
Benoit the thing is I have to say that I
believe that Jordan I think he's a
competitive and driven person yes so it
makes me think that if he really likes
Jenna he's gonna keep pushing for what
he wants even if she's still looking
around yeah I think sometimes it's good
especially for guys to to feel a little
bit jealous and then all of a sudden
feel like that's the girl I want and I
need to step up do your work put in the
effort Beth wants to know from paradise
who did you end up being good friends
with besides Chris so well I was friends
with Kendall before the show and we
remained really good friends and I
actually became really good friends with
Krystal which to me was a huge shocker
cuz I went in thinking she's probably
the person I would least want to see
there but she and I I think she was just
she was sort of like me she came into in
a different headspace and so we were
actually able to connect his friends but
she was like a surprise friend for me
that's awesome I interviewed her right
before filming started and she told me
she staged her thing so literally on
stage she brought sage with her she did
I loved it it was so nice to see that
moment between her and Bibiana last
night as well where they were kind of
hugging it out and yeah I mean are we
who would you say has had the big
redemptive biggest Redemption story this
season from their past seasons in the
franchise is it Krystal is it you grace
yeah me and Krystal I had are probably
the two biggest cuz Chris sort of wavers
back and forth but no I do you think
Krystal is like a new we're seeing it
completely different crystal this is I
think who she actually is I think in the
pressure of the of the bachelor world
and being in that environment we're all
competing for one guy the pressure got
to both of us and in different very
different ways and so this was just a
much more chill version there
moment last night when crystal was just
holding a margarita yeah I love this
crystal I love this what about the
biggest heartbreaks that we're gonna see
this season because I think we saw that
tonight leo is going to arrive Kendall
and Joe had this strong connection and
Kendall's gonna have a moment with Leo
who do you think has the most
heartbreaking moment of the season if
you look back at at all um there's gonna
be a lot of heartbreak though okay I'm
scared I'm scared for Joe we all love
Joe so much yeah I hope you powers
through a question we actually had
gotten from a fan earlier do you and did
everyone find the Colton and Tia
situation as annoying some people are
right now were you guys frustrated with
them in that moment are you like figure
it out I think we were frustrated just
because it felt like the first couple
weeks just revolved around them and we
all kind of just felt like we're on the
TN Colton show we're like okay more more
drama with them wills was here last week
and he kind of broke down in tears a
little really he said that he felt like
Colton no one really he just felt not
cared about because it's just was all
about cold and then his Tia stuff and
everything yeah um I can see that yeah I
felt like it was that was a big chunk of
the first couple weeks we were also
involved in it and it was it was funny I
had girlfriends texting me last night
they were like oh my gosh Colton why
were you going for : and I'm like he was
he was off-limits but yeah so it's it's
it was hard because being there we
really felt like they were you couldn't
touch them they were sort of these two
people that it was just like they need
to figure it out we're here just as
observers and giving feedback when we
can but we didn't feel like we were yeah
it just was it was weird those first
couple weeks it was definitely all about
them there was a funny moment last night
in the confessional where Tia turned to
the camera she just said help yeah
Mercedes wants to know because this is
up in the air right now who do you think
should be the next Bachelor oh gosh I
don't know
um I know Jason is like everyone's
excited about him right so I think he
would be a good one highly beloved I'm a
big fan of Jason too so I do also want
to talk to you
the moment when you kind of advised
Jordan last night you went over to and
you're like that's not cool what you
said I mean at that point had your
feelings for him
you were the past those I was literally
the minute Jenna walked in and he came
back and we had our chat I was like no
this is like I knew it was gonna be done
anyway so I was I was I closed that door
immediately and then it was just I was
looking out for him because I felt like
I had gotten to know him so much more
than some of the other people because he
was pursuing me so we did have lots of
one-on-one conversations and I felt like
I saw a much different side of him so
when he had that moment last night I was
I just thought like okay you know what
I I I need to go talk to him so I
followed him down we chatted but I was
really disappointed and how in how he
presented himself that night because
like I said to him last night it was
like that's not you you're better than
that and I was like what is this like
for the cameras are you actually pissed
like what is going on with you and so I
really wanted to like have a chat with
him and be like not cool go apologize
and I'm grateful that he did apologize
and I hope that he realizes now that
that wasn't okay what do you think it
was what had sent him over the edge I
honestly I think he just had a bit of a
breaking point that he just took too far
I don't think he meant for it to go that
far I think what happened was he just
felt he felt like he was in the outfit
David was doing the dog thing and I
think he just felt made fun of and it
was like maybe an ego thing where he
just felt like everyone was laughing at
him and so instead of just handling it
like a man he got in his head and lashed
out and just did not handle it I am
surprised by how well you responded when
he did have that chat with you and this
was on last week's episode but yeah it
was really funny to be Anneliese because
he sat down I I don't think he maybe
meant it to come across or maybe it was
edited it looked so harsh she was like
my date with Jenna was fantastic it was
an unbelievable connection like you and
I will never get there and then he walks
and tells Jenna he had such a good
healthy talk I mean it was harsh no it
was harsh in the moment it was harsh um
I'm glad he talked to me though he could
have just not talked
some God he did say something and him
saying it also just validated like okay
this isn't gonna happen and I can get
made it easier for me just to close that
door as well so I'm fine with that
okay it was very direct it was just
maybe I was like you didn't have to you
could have just said it's not working
out versus here's how amazing things are
going right I know but hey we'll take
the message yeah so you and Kenny last
night yeah and he gave you his rose less
okay unexpected for me but Kenny kind of
dated around a little bit what do you
think it was about I want him to see and
understand more about u2's connection
and maybe we'll get that on tonight's
what was it I feel like it wasn't really
shown our relationship up until up until
that point but he and I had so many long
long conversations like hours by the
pool just chatting and we were
completely friend-zoned like completely
and even so it was actually similar to
Krystal having her moment with Chris I
had a moment where it was right after
Krystal kind of ended it with Chris
ended it with Kenny and then I was
talking to her about it and I was like
you know what though because I was
saying you should date him like here's
all the great qualities about him and in
that moment I thought wait here's all
the great qualities about him maybe I
should consider this like if she's not
into it maybe I should consider this so
I remember like having the conversation
with him that night when I waited up for
him and and again it was just our
conversation was always so easy and and
I just I have nothing but good things to
say about Kenny I think he's a great guy
and so I felt like why why not we're all
here to find love again
and sometimes when you put somebody in
the friendzone it's hard to get out of
that friend zone so it was like that big
leap I think for both of us to be like
okay are we gonna try maybe to see if
there's something more so I think that
was last night what can you tease for us
that we might see tonight from you and
Kenny um I don't know I don't know if
you're gonna see to too much of us
tonight there's a lot but there was a
lot I didn't see it sounds like okay
there's a lot you didn't see yeah and I
think I mean I think the basis of our
relationship was a friendship and that's
like where you want to start every
relationship is with a friendship so so
I think it was a really nice place to
start a relationship and and
yeah it just in this environment things
grow very quickly and so I think that's
where it sort of went from like wait
where did this come from because you
don't really see us being even friends
and then we're just all of a sudden okay
kissing on a daybed so you know it's
always on a daybed paradise
I wondered too if you guys being both in
your 30s like a little bit of a
different age a little more mature that
that means you guys connect yeah I think
so I think there was a moment to where I
remember saying to him like for me a lot
of these people like go out all the time
and party and are meeting people and
that's not really my lifestyle anymore
so I just feel like I don't necessarily
want like I don't want to be here I sort
of need to be here in terms of like if I
want to actually date somebody in this
capacity and I felt like he really felt
that way to where it was like this is
the environment for somebody in their
30s to actually meet someone or you have
no distractions you don't have to worry
about all the stresses of real life and
it's not like going out to a club until
three o'clock in the morning and yeah I
loved that I have to say that is one
thing that I wish I mean it was such a
big deal on re-season that Becca M was
so young and I loved you being in your
30s on the show and I would love to see
more women and men in their 30s on the
show because you you really do there's a
validity in I've tried to find somebody
and I haven't I've had the time to tries
I think I'll say sometimes when
somebody's 22 you're like just give it a
minute
it's gonna be okay I want to ask you
overall which couple causes the most
drama this season well I think so far
we've already seen it okay who comes in
second thing oh I think I think maybe
Chris and Krystal just because we've
like sort of seen it already a little
bit okay is there more drama to come
from them I honestly can't really
remember I feel like the team potent
thing was such a big thing that
interesting it occupied all my headspace
okay I love it okay couple more
questions for you would you go on
reality TV again Amanda wants to know I
don't know I think if it was the right
opportunity I wouldn't I would have to
think about it but right now I feel like
that's probably it for me for reality TV
but we'll see also wanted to ask you am
burnham just had kind of a bachelorette
bash yeah I saw that
yeah I was wondering how involved are
the women from your season I don't know
how close you are with her but is
anybody gonna be going to any of these
pre-wedding things or going to the
wedding itself where's Jacqueline I
think was the only person from our
season that was there but she is I mean
she is close with mikkel and I mean I
talked to her every once in a while
we're not super super close but we I
mean I think with our season we really
got along there was maybe just like a
couple girls that were a little bit more
clicky but that wasn't to say that they
didn't still get along with everyone so
I don't know I think it's gonna be a
really small private wedding though so I
have a feeling that it won't be a ton of
people from from bachelor world got it
okay any idea if it'll be televised have
you heard I don't I think I heard that
it's not but we'll see it all through
social media I'm sure all right well
tonight we have another episode of
bachelor in paradise on ABC you guys two
more fabulous hours and Benoit comes and
Leo comes and drama comes if you could
describe the rest of the season and a
couple adjectives what do we have in
store
ah drama hot steamy uh I don't know all
the things I love in season in Paradise
I have to say it's really good I think
everybody is really bringing it and it's
a feeling like the emotions are running
high in there we are
yeah and you're definitely gonna see a
lot of love too so all right well we
can't wait to see how things turned out
for you Annalise so glad it seems like
not as much drama this season no
everybody follow Annalise on social
media and of course watch bachelor in
paradise tonight on ABC and every Monday
and Tuesday also tomorrow morning we
will have a new episode of roses and
Rosie up for you recapping both episodes
from this week and we love you guys so
much thanks for watching everybody
thanks
[Music]
you